hola bienvenidos a este especial de
migrantes el programa semanal de france
24 sobre el éxodo
[Música]
en un año particularmente convulso a
causa del cobi 19 los migrantes
refugiados y desplazados sufrieron el
impacto del virus directamente la
pandemia de afecta de manera
desproporcionada a una población
extremadamente vulnerable que vive lejos
de su hogar no cuenta con empleos
formales y para quienes la recomendación
de quedarse en casa resulta una paradoja
lejos de paralizar el tránsito de los
que huyen la pandemia alimentó la
migración por rutas clandestinas y qué
hacer cuando los conflictos la
persecución y el hambre no cesan a causa
de la pandemia y cómo enfrentar una
realidad desconocida en los países de
acogida cuando una enfermedad paralizó
al mundo en este programa revisaremos la
situación de los migrantes y refugiados
de venezuela centroamérica y los que
buscaron llegar a europa en 2020 y para
eso contaremos con eduardo stein
representante especial de acnur y de la
óyeme para los refugiados venezolanos y
maría jesús vega portavoz de acnur en
españa también estaban en este especial
nuestras corresponsales en caracas
honduras y marruecos
empezamos con el caso de los migrantes y
refugiados venezolanos según naciones
unidas más de 5 millones de ciudadanos
han salido de venezuela impulsados por
la crisis social económica y política en
su país en busca de un mejor futuro para
ellos y sus familias la mayoría se
instaló en colombia y otro buen número
en diferentes países de suramérica pero
la vida que empezaban a construir en un
país ajeno les cambió con la llegada del
cob y 19 veamos más en el siguiente
informe son los migrantes baratos del
coronavirus cuyas secuelas económicas
afectaron especialmente a las vidas de
millones de migrantes y refugiados
venezolanos la mayoría trabajadores
informales que ni siquiera contaban con
un techo bajo el que pasar las estrictas
cuarentena arrojando de nuestro arriendo
ella no tenemos trabajo no tenemos como
ella ni alimentar a los niños está muy
difícil en la calle sin trabajo ni
dinero para sostener a sus familias en
su país de adopción colombia al menos
100 mil venezolanos volvieron a empacar
sus escasas pertenencias para emprender
un camino de retorno a venezuela donde
tiempo atrás huyeron en busca de una
vida digna debido a la crisis
humanitaria que asola la nación a
nosotros los venezolanos no nos están
matando el corona vino sino el hambre
por eso estamos aquí en la trocha
luchando para sobrevivir sin embargo el
cierre de los pasos fronterizos entre
colombia y venezuela hizo que familias
enteras quedaran varadas en las
carreteras del país
[Música]
historias que se replican desde
venezuela que acoge a casi 2 millones de
venezolanos hasta brasil perú o chile
problema para siempre regularizar me
luego salió la pandemia y aquí estamos
ante este retorno masivo durante la
cuarentena el gobierno colombiano
financió a unos 1.200 autobuses para
trasladar a los migrantes hacia el
puente internacional simón bolívar otros
lo harían por peligrosos pasos
irregulares unos aire por la trocha hay
peligro hay vandalismo ahí todo el toro
mal pero no nos queda otro remedio que
pasan obligatoriamente por la necesidad
que tenemos por su parte el presidente
nicolás maduro acusaba a su homólogo
colombiano de contaminar a su país
enviando personas contagiadas mientras
el cansancio acumulado se hacía cada vez
más visible desesperación
en nuestro país
y no dude
también
d
y el virus también golpea su precaria
salud las organizaciones humanitarias
levantaron improvisados campamentos en
mitad del trayecto pero rápidamente se
vieron saturados esto no es un albergue
esto no es un refugio se trata de la
estación sanitaria de atención tienditas
donde los migrantes que están retornando
hacia el territorio venezolano cada 48
horas en grupos de 300 personas
ingresaron al territorio venezolano en
condiciones de dignidad sin embargo
volver no era garantía de una mejor vida
muchos de los que lograron regresar se
encontraron de nuevo con la crisis
económica y social agravada por la
pandemia que desangra venezuela ahora
con el alivio de las restricciones y la
reapertura económica emprenden de nuevo
un largo camino hacia los países de
acogida
adulto no podemos aguantar
un bebé de 5 años que no tiene nada en
su casa que no tiene un alimento son los
migrantes varados del cob y 19 personas
que lo han perdido todo a los dos lados
del camino y aún así siguen moviéndose
con la esperanza de una vida digna pero
el tránsito terrestre no es el único
usado por los venezolanos para salir del
país una peligrosa ruta clandestina a
través del mar caribe es otra opción
para las personas que buscan partir de
venezuela la noticia sobre la
desaparición de un grupo de venezolanos
en su mayoría menores en alta mar reveló
la crítica situación de los que huyen
rumbo a trinidad y tobago nuestra
corresponsal en caracas herminia
fernández nos profundiza sobre la
situación de los que migran hacia las
islas del caribe el gobierno de trinidad
y tobago ha sido uno de los más
estrictos con la entrada de inmigrantes
venezolanos a su territorio las dos
islas se ubican a apenas 100 km de
distancia de venezuela una cercanía que
ha abierto el camino para los viajes en
bote de bajo coste el tráfico de armas
drogas contrabando de alimentos
combustibles pero también la búsqueda de
mejor calidad de vida para muchas
personas que han sido afectadas por
económica del país este año las
autoridades trinitarias han detenido las
playas a cientos de personas y la
mayoría de ellas han sido devueltas a
territorio venezolano de los más de
24.000 de ciudadanos venezolanos que
reciben en trinidad y tobago 17 mil 391
han solicitado refugio y eso los 1.196
les han reconocido esta condición las
personas que deciden irse especialmente
los jóvenes pagan seiscientos euros para
que los lleven de manera ilegal a
trinidad en embarcaciones que no son
aptas para la navegación en esas aguas
esto ha generado un crecimiento en los
naufragios y en la cantidad de personas
muertas o desaparecidas se calcula que
al menos 102 venezolanos han muerto en
el cruce entre el estado sucre y
trinidad y tobago muchos de ellos eran
niños que emigraron con sus familias las
últimas 20 víctimas fueron encontradas a
principios de diciembre y aún siguen
buscando cuerpos tras el naufragio de
una embarcación nos acompaña en este
especial eduardo stein representante
especial de acnur y de la organización
internacional para las migraciones para
los refugiados venezolanos
gracias por acompañarnos quiero empezar
preguntándole fue el retorno una opción
acertada para los venezolanos son más
bien faltó acción por parte de los
países de acogida para garantizar que
ellos pudieran quedarse y no tuvieran
que optar por el retorno
compleja su pregunta juliette gracias
por el interés un saludo a la
teleaudiencia df 24 en realidad para ser
estrictos en la valoración de lo que me
preguntas
la
digamos
complejidad la
vastedad el impacto tan brutal de la
pandemia
contrajo las economías de los países
receptores de emigración venezolana
haciendo muy difícil la
agenda económica general para
poblaciones en donde en varios de los
países receptores hay todavía
porcentajes muy grandes de población
local que vive y sobrevive en la
informalidad
espacio en el cual muchas y muchos de
los venezolanos habían encontrado medios
de vida aunque modestos pero ya digamos
sin
representar una carga
exorbitante como durante los primeros
meses y años de la del éxodo venezolano
representó para la mayoría de gobiernos
receptores para contestar tu pregunta
cerca de 130.000
venezolanas y venezolanos
al verse en condiciones tan precarias en
los países de acogida
tomaron la decisión de retornar a su
país venezuela y se encontraron con
condiciones muy distintas de aquellas
que dejaron hacía meses o años
con condiciones de muchísima mayor
escasez con dificultades incluso de
accesos elementales a la alimentación y
a servicios de salud sí señor stein yo
quiero preguntarle específicamente por
estos migrantes que retornaron pero que
luego tuvieron que volver o que luego
regresaron a los países de acogida qué
impacto va a tener esto para los países
receptores de la región con este nuevo
éxodo desde venezuela teniendo en cuenta
que algunas organizaciones dicen que
seguramente van a migrar con un miembro
de su familia más
bueno juliette lo que estamos nosotros
viendo y detectando en los puestos
fronterizos es que de un
movimiento casi
nulo por decirlo de manera legal a
través de puestos fronterizos oficiales
de los gobiernos
lo que se vivió fue un pequeño goteo de
inmigrantes venezolanos hacia los países
vecinos por trochas o veredas o pasos
irregulares
esto se está incrementando conforme los
controles fronterizos que impusieron los
países receptores por razón de la
pandemia para controlar
la expansión de contagios se van
aflojando
estamos ahora ante cerca de 500 a 700
personas
diarias de manera que el flujo se ha
incrementado no no alcanzamos a
distinguir en este minuto cuáles son
personas que están retornando por
segunda vez a los países de acogida
dejando por segunda vez su territorio y
cuáles son las migraciones nuevas lo que
sí podemos determinar es que la mayoría
de estas personas se están arriesgando a
cruzar por vías irregulares
poniéndose en manos de traficantes lo
que
incrementa considerablemente los riesgos
de la travesía sí señor este y lo invito
para que de venezuela- revisemos ahora
el tránsito de los centroamericanos
hacia el norte la pandemia obligó a
miles de personas que viven bajo la
amenaza de la violencia de las pandillas
y la pobreza a quedarse en casa en que
no era seguro para ellos las
restricciones de movilidad para usaron
el tránsito de miles de personas que
emigran en grupos desde los países del
llamado triángulo norte hacia eeuu
mientras las fronteras permanecieron
cerradas el éxodo estuvo en pausa pero
una vez se informó sobre la reapertura
de los pasos se reactivaron las
caravanas de centroamericanos que se
forman por un llamado a través de redes
sociales y que partieron en su mayoría
desde san pedro sula en honduras un
recorrido que esperaba los llevar a la
unión americana pero que fue bloqueado
una vez comenzaron a avanzar por otros
países la seguridad sanitaria preocupó a
las autoridades de países como guatemala
que contuvieron el avance de los
migrantes durante las últimas semanas
del año la emergencia causada por los
huracanes eta e io está en centroamérica
incremento la huida de los
centroamericanos
nuestra corresponsal en honduras kenia
torres nos informa sobre la más reciente
caravana que se formó en el país de
quienes perdieron lo poco que tenían a
causa de los huracanes eta idiota
tras el embate de los huracanes está
ello está en honduras que dejaron
alrededor de un centenar de muertos y
según organismos de socorro unos tres
millones de perjudicados dos caravanas
han emprendido a la peligrosa ruta hacia
los eeuu en busca del llamado sueño
americano según testimonio de estas
personas lo perdieron todo durante el
embate de este fenómeno natural sin
embargo en lo que va del año unas cinco
caravanas han salido hacia los eeuu y la
pandemia del hobbit 19 ni las
restricciones impuestas por el gobierno
de guatemala una ruta obligatoria de
paso han impedido que estos hondureños
se marchen orillados por la situación de
pobreza en la que vive de este país
además la falta de empleo y la idea de
una reunificación familiar según
estadísticas de la organización de las
naciones unidas por lo menos en las
últimas décadas alrededor de un millón
de hondureños ha emigrado
país de destino mayormente es eeuu en un
segundo lugar españa y en forma
minoritaria
méxico
vuelvo con el señor eduardo stein cuál
es el riesgo que corren los
centroamericanos que necesitan
desplazarse a otro país pero que por la
pandemia no pueden hacerlo y deben
quedarse en un lugar que es inseguro
para ellos
bueno los riesgos son
diversos dependiendo de los territorios
si son más o menos
controlados
pandillas o por el narcotráfico que
utiliza a las pandillas como
instrumentos digamos de control
territorial
tendría tres formas de responderle para
que se entienda mejor esta complicada
situación
una que es el calendario político todo
el mundo está esperando que asuma el
presidente electo joe biden en los eeuu
y la digamos transmisión de mando está
resultando para todos los países del
mundo que tenemos relación con este país
y en particular nosotros en honduras
salvador y guatemala
que estamos tan cerca de ellos y
representamos
desafortunadamente un riesgo de
seguridad
todo el mundo está esperando cómo será
la nueva agenda de manejo migratorio
distinta como ya se conoce al menos por
anuncios de lo que fue la dureza con que
el presidente trump nos trató pero lo
más importante de su pregunta es cuál es
la situación humana personal familiar
comunitaria de esta población que ve
amenazada su seguridad en algunos de los
territorios porque las fuerzas de
seguridad de nuestros tres gobiernos no
han sido capaces de garantizar la
seguridad y la integridad de estas
personas ese es el riesgo mayor que
están enfrentando algunas de estas
mujeres y hombres que se atreven a una
travesía tan riesgosa al señor eduardo
stein representante especial de acnur y
de la óyeme por acompañarnos gracias en
este especial emigrar es también el
último recurso para miles de personas de
los países de medio oriente
a su hogar no es un sitio seguro pero el
tránsito hacia europa tampoco lo es
muchos son los que se embarcan en rutas
marítimas peligrosas y no todos logran
ver las costas europeas miles de vidas
se pierden en el mar anualmente y el coi
19 sirvió de excusa para bloquear a ongs
de salvamento que navega en el
mediterráneo
marina sardiña nos muestra más del viaje
hacia el viejo continente en el 2020
el cierre de fronteras fue la primera
medida que tomaron los gobiernos
europeos con la llegada de la pandemia y
ellos los refugiados inmigrantes en ruta
sus principales víctimas cuando el mundo
se paró por el cob y 19 miles de
refugiados procedentes de medio oriente
y áfrica serían en movimiento
arriesgando sus vidas en el mar
mediterráneo huyendo de la guerra del
hambre o las persecuciones que viven en
sus países de origen vince trending dead
block han quedado varados están
bloqueados algunos en grandes grupos
otros en pequeños grupos en las zonas
fronterizas en condiciones muy difíciles
sin acceso a una atención mínima
especialmente a los chequeos de salud
screening el mar mediterráneo es la ruta
más mortífera del mundo al menos mil 96
personas han fallecido en 2020
intentando llegar a europa según los
datos del proyecto migrantes
desaparecidos de la o&m sumado a los
desafíos de esta peligrosa travesía
estaba ahora el riesgo de contagio
agravado por las condiciones de
hacinamiento en las pateras mientras se
impedía a las organizaciones
humanitarias realizar labores de
búsqueda y rescate y en los países
puerta de entrada de la migración
europea los gobiernos usaban el
coronavirus excusa para no dejar
desembarcar a las personas rescatadas si
italia no considera seguro sus puertos
por el hobbit 19 porque reconoce a libia
como lugar seguro y financia junto con
la unión europea a grupos armados y
campos de detención en su territorio con
el alivio de las restricciones en junio
los activistas pudieron volver a sus
barcos de rescate adecuados con
protocolos de bioseguridad sin embargo
en tierra la situación no era mejor con
las restricciones de movilidad en marzo
gobiernos como el griego anunciaron la
suspensión temporal de los
reasentamientos y las tramitaciones de
peticiones de asilo dejando varados
familias de refugiados en la frontera
entre grecia y turquía muchos refugiados
y ong denunciaban devoluciones en
caliente en septiembre la desesperación
y el hartazgo de miles de personas
aisladas y atinadas en el mayor
campamento de refugiados de europa moria
provocaron un incendio que arrasó con el
hogar de 13.000 personas en la isla
griega de lesbos el fuego demostró la
ineficiencia de las instituciones
europeas en materia de migración y la
falta de solidaridad de sus gobiernos
los eventos de anoche son el resultado
de cinco años de políticas progresivas
de confinamiento y contención llevadas a
cabo tanto por el gobierno local como
por los gobiernos europeos juntos
tras la devastación se construyó
apresuradamente un nuevo campamento en
la costa griega muchos se negaron a
ingresar pese a las amenazas de las
autoridades sin embargo el nuevo campo
no soluciona los problemas estructurales
y las carencias de miles de personas
es como una cárcel no dejan a la gente
entrar ni salir de allí es una prisión
es el kobe 19 captó toda la atención
durante el 2020 mientras ellos los
refugiados que esperaban tras huir de
sus países ven como europa los olvida
una vez más
y una vieja ruta concentró la atención
de las noticias sobre migración hacia
europa durante las últimas semanas del
2020 miles navegaron en pequeños barcos
barcos desde las costas africanas rumbo
al archipiélago español de las islas
canarias sofía a catalá desde marrakech
nos reportó sobre el éxodo por esta ruta
y las medidas tomadas por europa para
contener el tránsito la militarización
de las rutas del mediterráneo ha llevado
a muchas personas migrantes asumir rutas
más peligrosas como es el caso de las
que pasan por el océano atlántico en
dirección a las islas canarias estas
personas no tienen acceso a los visados
que exige la unión europea para
transitar de forma segura hacia su
territorio por lo que lo hacen en
embarcaciones no aptas para navegar que
salen en su mayoría de marruecos
mauritania y senegal en un año
centenares de mujeres hombres y niños
han muerto o desaparecido en el océano
atlántico aunque en realidad podrían ser
incluso muchas más porque la mayoría de
muertes simplemente no constan y el
flujo migratorio hacia las islas
españolas ha sido este año más de diez
veces mayor al año pasado como decimos
por el bloqueo del mediterráneo y la
estrategia del gobierno de españa' para
reducirlo pasa ahora por retener a los
inmigrantes que consiguen llegar a las
es decir las personas que son rescatadas
del océano atlántico son automáticamente
retenidas para ser en su mayoría después
deportadas y para ello el gobierno
español y también la propia unión
europea siguen reforzando los
dispositivos de externalización del
control migratorio es decir el pagar y
ofrecer material de vigilancia a países
terceros para que persigan y bloqueen la
salida de inmigrantes hacia la unión
europea de hecho la propia comisaria
europea de migraciones se va johansson
estuvo este mes aquí en marruecos
tratando de conseguir un acuerdo para
poder expulsar personas de diferentes
nacionalidades desde la unión europea
hasta marruecos y el país magrebí
consciente de las contrapartidas
económicas y diplomáticas que puede
exigir a la unión europea se muestra
ahora reticente a ejercer de gendarme de
las fronteras europeas en palabras del
propio ministro de asuntos exteriores
naser han bolita lo que muchos analistas
consideran podría servir para el
reconocimiento de la soberanía marroquí
sobre el sáhara occidental y en este
contexto cabe tener en cuenta que
marruecos aparte de ser país de
emigrantes también lo es de tránsito y
acogida de inmigrantes y que la
ejecución de las políticas migratorias
europeas aquí impide al estado
garantizar los derechos más básicos a
estas comunidades
otra parte también tener en cuenta que
españa y la unión europea también siguen
reforzando los acuerdos con mauritania y
senegal para poder bloquear a los
migrantes y también deportarlos desde
canarias
saludo ahora a maría jesús vega portavoz
de acnur en españa' señora maria jesus
gracias por estar con nosotros
emigrantes y empiezo a preguntar
preguntándole sobre europa vimos durante
el 2020 varios escenarios más migrantes
a través de la ruta por el mediterráneo
un campo de memoria quemado y un camino
que volvió a reactivarse por el
atlántico para los migrantes africanos y
que y que los lleva hacia las islas
canarias que lecturas le daría usted al
éxodo hacia ese continente cuando el
virus todavía sigue activo
bueno yo creo que ahora mismo europa no
se puede permitir el
continuar cometiendo los errores que se
cometieron en el pasado cuando vimos esa
llegada tan grande de personas un millón
de personas hacia grecia e italia
castaña sirios iraquíes afganos
personas que buscaban lugares seguros en
este momento hace falta en europa que
haya una solidaridad un reparto de
responsabilidades hace falta que todos
los estados arrimen el hombro para poder
tener un sistema
común de asilo y de migraciones y el
pacto europeo sobre inmigración que se
aprobó el pasado mes de septiembre es
una oportunidad para que en su puesta en
marcha se pueda trabajar en lugar de
esos enfoques a dos crisis a crisis
barco a barco caso a caso el poder
hacerlo de una manera predecible y de
una manera armonizada entre todos los
estados que no sea una lotería
en un estado o en otro y sobre todo que
se respete el derecho a pedir asilo para
aquellas personas que están huyendo
porque su vida corre peligro huyendo de
la guerra de la persecución y que
necesitan poder tener acceso a unos
procedimientos de reconocimiento de la
condición de refugiado ahí van a
encontrar desde luego los estados toda
la colaboración y todo el apoyo de acnur
precisamente sobre esto que usted toca
en este momento quedan entonces los
migrantes en medio de una situación
política siendo que esto es una crisis
humanitaria
bueno si haber crisis humanitaria
tenemos esta pandemia tremenda que está
provocando que es una crisis sobre una
crisis humanitaria que ya que ya hay
sobre todo lo que estamos viendo en este
momento es que la pandemia ha afectado
políticas y prácticas de inmigración y
de asilo en este momento lo que tenemos
claro es que salvar vidas tiene que ser
la prioridad y esto no es discutible
estamos viendo a diario gente muriendo
cada año son centenares de personas que
pierden la vida en los mares en los
desiertos en las fronteras intentando
alcanzar lugares seguros y cuando vemos
que a pesar del cierre de fronteras a
pesar del confinamiento a pesar del
trato brutal al que se somete a estas
personas por parte de mafias y de estas
redes de trata que que abusan de la
desesperación ajena vemos que sigue
habiendo gente que arriesga la vida la
vida de sus hijos la propia por alcanzar
la seguridad yo creo que nos tiene que
hacer pensar que no tienen otra opción y
que lo que dejan atrás es infinitamente
peor y con ello que hace falta hacer
mucho más para tener vías legales y
seguras de entrada para tener más
programas de reasentamiento
reunificaciones familiares
formas que eviten que la gente vuelva a
arriesgar la vida de nuevo y sobre todo
el trabajar para prevenir y para
resolver conflictos y bueno pues
efectivamente aunque ese virus y sigue
activo como como comentaba se ha
paralizado a medio mundo pero las
guerras no las ha paralizado si es
señora maría jesús para cerrar esta
especial le pregunto cómo cambió la
pandemia de coronavirus la migración en
el mundo
yo creo que la pandemia
está sirviendo para hacer una reflexión
general porque esa parálisis que ha
habido ese cierre de espacio aéreo ese
esa situación en la que nos hemos tenido
que quedar todos en casa donde nos hemos
quedado sin conexión con los seres
queridos donde no nos hemos podido
despedir de la gente yo creo que nos
tiene que servir para darnos cuenta que
en el mundo sigue habiendo personas que
están en esa situación y han estado en
esa situación de pandemia
encerrados y sin libertad privados de
muchos derechos pero no porque haya un
virus y que sea el bien común el que el
que permita y el que diga que quedarse
en casa sino porque les están amenazando
porque les están extorsionando porque su
vida corre peligro y así hay 80 millones
de personas así que yo creo que es un
buen momento para reflexionar para
ponernos en la piel de todas esas
personas y para que nos demos cuenta que
hace falta un enfoque común y hace falta
que todos podamos trabajar para tratar
de darles una esperanza y una vida mejor
a millones de personas
que no han hecho no ha cometido ningún
delito más que estar en el lugar
equivocado con hacer en un país en el
que hay en ese momento pues violencia
guerra o conflicto señora maría jesús
vega portavoz de acnur en españa gracias
por acompañarnos en este especial de
emigrantes
gracias a ustedes y a ustedes también
gracias por acompañarnos los invitamos a
comentar en las redes sociales con el
hashtag migrantes f24 siga con más
programación en france 24 y france 24
puntocom
[Música]